coût et les siens place au dernier débat
de cette émission consacrée à facebook
car elle s'appelle français sauguet neil
à 37 ans elle est ingénieure
informaticienne elle a travaillé pendant
deux ans à la division intégrité civique
ça ne s'invente pas de facebook et puis
elle en est partie des secrets plein les
poches et depuis l entame et il ne
tournée mondiale n était cet après midi
au sénat auditionné par les sénateurs
pour les appeler à réguler et à réguler
facebook pourquoi et comment c'est ce
dont on va parler et notamment sur la
question des algorithmes vous propose de
regarder d'abord un extrait d'un
documentaire sur les algorithmes de
facebook sur la façon dont ils
conditionnent ou non nos opinions
politiques le fil d'actualité c'est
l'horizon absolue de ce que voit un
profil sur facebook
ce fil d'actualités ne ressemble pas à
un média classique les informations
qu'on peut y consulter ne répond pas à
une ligne éditoriale et ne présentent
pas l'actualité du moment
chaque individu sur la planète à son
propre fils d'actualités qui nous
ressemble pas à celui du voisin dessus
viennent s'agréger des contenus ces
contenus sont en gros pour faire simple
ce qui a été partagé par vos amis ce qui
est produit par les pages que vous avez
décidé d'aimer et ce qui est produit
dans les groupes auxquels vous adhérez
tout ça est mélangé dans une tambouille
algorithmique qui va faire remonter des
cendres apparaître ou disparaître
certains types de contenus que jeune
c'était un instant vont être privilégiés
les contenus les plus viraux c'est à
dire ce que vous allez partager le plus
loin et le plus rapidement possible ces
algues au rythme là organisent
aujourd'hui l'ensemble de la
conversation de facebook et donc votre
propre expérience de facebook c'est
facebook qui va décider au final ce à
quoi vous allez être exposés alors
faut-il réguler facebook faut-il le
démanteler faute il s'attaquait aux
halles gorille on va en parler ce soir
avec mes invités tout d'abord jean
bernard schmid parce que c'était un
documentaire que vous roduit vous êtes
co fondateur et dirigeant de ce pays si
la plateforme indépendante de
documentaires merci beaucoup de nous
avoir rejoints pour ce débat à vos côtés
catherine morin desailly vous êtes
sénatrice centriste de seine maritime et
vous êtes la personne idoine pour ce
n'est pas parce que vous êtes une
spécialiste des lanceurs d alerte
comment vous jouez vous avez soutenu
édouard snowden est fait et puis vous
êtes une spécialiste du numérique et
puis vous avez la chance d'auditionner
deux fois française hogen cet après midi
au sénat mais vous l'aviez fait aussi
lundi yeah yeah à bruxelles dès hier à
bruxelles non pas lundi pardon à vos
côtés à ce moment là vous êtes maître de
conférences à sciences po et spécialiste
des politiques du numérique et puis bien
sûr mais titia copains qui restent avec
moi on va écouter ce que disent les
français sont game cet après midi au
sénat
après le congrès américain et plusieurs
parlement européen devant les sénateurs
français sauvent gun a de nouveau fait
un diagnostic cinglant facebook
représente un risque pour les
démocraties car seul compte pour
l'entreprise la logique de rentabilité
facebook est devenu une entreprise de
1000 milliards de dollars en engrangeant
des bénéfices aux dépens de notre
sécurité y compris celles de nos enfants
c'est inacceptable
les sénateurs ont interrogé la lanceuse
d' alerte sur les moyens existants en
france pour réguler le réseau social et
notamment sur le nombre de modérateur
est-ce que vous avez un ordre de
grandeur ce qui fait un chiffre précis
du nombre de modérateur francophone pour
les modérateurs français francophones on
a trop peu
facebook c'est que la plus grosse menace
pour l'entreprise c'est si quelque chose
devient toxique ce aux états unis et ils
ont sous investi là où ils ne se sentent
pas menacés français sauvent gun a
appelé les sénateurs qui vont travailler
sur la loi européenne la digital
services act à saisir la chance de cette
loi qui pourrait devenir une référence
en matière de régulation des plateformes
la législation de l'ue a un énorme
potentiel
elle n'essaie pas de supprimer le
problème avec des réglementations sur le
contenu elle adopte une approche neutre
en termes de contenu pour s'attaquer aux
risques systémiques et aux méfaits du
problème du modèle commercial
les sénateurs ont également interrogé
français se gagnent sur les menaces qui
pèsent sur elle en tant que lanceuse d'
alerte
alors la première question que j'ai
envie de vous poser parce que c'est pas
la première fois qu'on a des révélations
sur les errements les fautes les erreurs
de facebook c est ce que les révélations
de france face aux glens vous ont
surpris et j'ai commencé avec vous
catherine c est ce que vous avez appris
qu est ce qu elle vous a appris que vous
ne sachiez déjà elle a donné des
précisions sur le fonctionnement interne
de facebook ce qu'il y a longtemps été
travaillé travaillé elle ya travaillé
longtemps c'est une spécialiste wallace
et du web et spécialiste des algorithmes
donc ça c'est essentiel c'est au coeur
du sujet mais nous avions eu plusieurs
alertes auparavant edouard snowdon je
rappelle que l'uimm sénat lancer une
mission d'information sur ce sujet j'en
suis le rapporteur en 2015 donc alerte
de d'edouard ce matin nous avons la
sphère cambridge analytique ou un
ingénieur dont deux facebook annonce qui
avait des failles dans lesquelles
s'était infiltré les russes et que avec
la complicité d'une entreprise de
traitement de données corrigées et icap
facebook avait livré les données d'à peu
près 85 millions d'internautes donc on
connaissait en fait le dysfonctionnement
majeur les effets désastreux de facebook
sur la manipulation potentiel d opinion
publique à la veille de scrutins majeurs
dont elle n'a fait que confirmer ce que
nous avions établi ici au sénat et nous
a donné des billets en quelque sorte
pour travailler sur le dais ça dont je
suis rapporteur avec ma collègue
florence béatrice comptable pour le
compte de notre européenne jean bernard
schmidt elle a égrainé tout un nombre de
révélations font face au ghana vous vous
avez été surpris en fait énormément de
choses qu'on savait ce que je trouve qui
est vraiment très important c'est qu'on
comprend que facebook c'est aussi c'est
ça le pire c'est qu'en fait on a enquêté
vous avez raison cambridge analytica
c'est vraiment une une enquête
importante sur les dysfonctionnements et
les intentions aussi on pourrait revenir
peut-être de facebook
on a vu ce qui s'est passé avec
l'élection donald trump avec le capitole
la polarisation la radicalisation et
c'est ce qui est terrible dans toutes
ces révélations c'est qu'on voit que
facebook c'est non seulement facebook
c'est mais facebook expérimente vous
avez passé là un extrait de la nouvelle
fabrique de l'opinion donc documentaire
que nous avons produit chez ce pas ici
réalisé par thomas bichon en 2019 ce
documentaire il repose sur un principe
simple on a créé de faux comptes
facebook pour voir comment lors d'une
campagne électorale il se polarise et il
se radicalise à cause des groupes dans
lesquels ils sont enfermés par les
algorithmes et finalement des bulles de
filtres informationnel que que les
algorithmes créé ce qu'on voit et ce
qu'on sait parmi les révélations de
français se gagnent c'est que facebook
quasiment au même moment à fait la même
chose que nous c'est incroyable terre
qu'ils ont eux mêmes créé de faux
comptes pour voir exactement et ils se
sont rendu compte de quoi mais ils ont
fait exactement la même compte le même
constat et la même conclusion que la
nôtre les comptes se radicalise à une
vitesse phénoménale et ils n'ont pas
forcément de conclusion je vous confesse
l'âme à la française au ghana un tournée
a entamé une véritable tournée mondiale
médiatique politique est ce que c'est à
la fois l'ampleur des découvertes ou la
façon dont elle les communique qui nous
surprend ou
alors c'est l'ampleur de la durée youn
mans que son discours a eu en fait c'est
un plan marketing et enfin plan média
qui était parfaitement millimétrée elle
est très soutenue elle est très
conseillé on le sait
l'umih n'était notamment un milliardaire
franco américain fondateur d'ibm est
donc en fait elles sont sûrs qu'il est
soutenu par semaine
et donc elle a à la halle un discours
extrêmement articulé très en fait qui
est absolument
cadrés pour pour pour sa cible qui sont
en fait d'une part l'opinion publique et
ensuite les régulateurs ou les
politiques et ce qui est intéressant
alors sur la première question non il
n'y a pas tellement de révélations ce
n'est qu'en fait là où je suis un tout
petit peu en désaccord c'est que c'est
pas oui il ya beaucoup d'expérimentation
mais c'est la règle du jeu puisque en
fait c'est la technologie elle-même et
innovatrice et disruptive mais ce qui
est étonnant c'est qu'en fait on
s'aperçoit surtout que ses algorithmes
là et ces entreprises là échappe
totalement à leurs créateurs en réaliser
et qu'on ne sait pas modérés oui et nous
vous souhaitons qu'elle est manipulée
pour vous non n'est pas manipulé en
revanche à la une à la une a là un
discours qui est extrêmement contrôlée
avec une finalité qui semble assez clair
vraiment je termine juste qui est un
tout petit peu étonnant enfin - en tout
cas ce qui me gêne un tout petit peu
dans dans sa posture c'est que en
réalité c'est très convenue en effet on
est tous en train de dire qu'on apprend
pas grand chose en fait et du coup en
terme de techno critique ses distances
l'intérêt c'est justement de
sensibiliser l'opinion publique mais
n'empêche que les les skis les
révélations sont assez convenue en fait
là où je suis mais indépendante parce
que c'est une lanceuse alerte
indépendante pour elle à un système qui
est très organisée autour d'elle pour
bien communiquer pour atteindre sa cible
bon malgré tout c'est très important que
il y des personnes comme m qui disent
explicitement de manière très claire au
grand public ce qui se passe là où je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec vous
c'est que vous dites que le système a
échappé ses créateurs non quand on
interroge faisait son gain écoutez ce
que nous avons la réponse que nous a
faite aujourd'hui elle dit qu'il
maîtrise très bien les algorithmes sont
conçus pour créer de la tension c'est
l'économie de l'attention qui est
théorisée par le professeur d'harvard
sojana zubov qui dit bien que sciemment
ils retiennent avec les algorithmes
l'attention voire façonnent nos clients
et crée une forme d'un décret forme
d'addiction
bien quelqu'un georg ricqlès qui nous a
rejoints depuis bruxelles où il est
installé vous êtes directeur associé du
european policy center et vous avez
beaucoup côtoyé vous les lobbys du
numérique parce que vous avez travaillé
pour la commission européenne sur le
sujet du marché unique numérique et sur
la question notamment des droits
d'auteur est ce qu'une femme comme
francis hogan est de taille à lutter
contre les lobbys de ces géants du
numérique pour vous guérir ricqlès
moi je trouve que ce que fait français
ce regain est d'une importance vitale
parce qu'elle met vraiment l'attention
sur les pratiques qui les plus néfastes
de facebook au moment où de nouvelles
lois sur la transparence sur la
régulation de ces plateformes sont
discutées au parlement européen et le
conseil des ministres donc je pense que
le la sortie de deux français sur
guesnes sa tournée en europe on peut
certes regarder qui est derrière qui la
soutient mais je pense que c'est juste
que quelqu'un comme français sagan
reçoit un soutien parce que les lobbys
les gars femmes les grands plats
plateforme n'ont pas de problème de
moyens dans le travail qu'elles font
pour se faire entendre ici à vous c'est
de se faire entendre dans les capitales
ont été directement témoin c'est j'ose
dire
oui tout à fait tout est permis moi
j'entendais l'autre jour deux dindes et
des grands lobbyistes ici à bruxelles
qui racontait que pour rappel la lega la
législation dès ma ds à en cours c'est
la plus grande menace réglementaire à
leurs business models et apple qui fait
des dizaines de milliards de dollars de
profits par an qu'est ce qui les empêche
alors de d'utiliser 100 mille euros 500
mille euros 2 millions d'euros 20
millions d'euros pour essayer
d'influencer et changer le cours de
cette législation pour eux ce sont des
cacahuètes donc naturellement ces
plateformes ses acteurs le fond donc
nous avons besoin
d'une démocratie active nous avons
besoin de lanceurs dallaire nous avons
besoin des parlementaires qui
s'investissent et c'est fondamental
en ce moment merci merci beaucoup goergl
reckless au coeur des critiques on
retrouve donc la question de ces
fameuses algues au rythme alors juste
pour le téléspectateur à ce moment là
est ce que vous nous expliquer ce qu'est
un algorithme et pourquoi ça peut être
dangereux quand ça fonctionne assez des
outils en fait c'est des arbres de
décision donc des codes qui sont qui
sont là pour automatiser un certain
nombre d'actions les industrialiser à
échelle voilà technologique et donc en
l'occurrence sur la question des réseaux
sociaux ce sont des algorithmes de
recommandation d'un cancer ce qui va
faire que tel ou tel contenu va être
davantage mis en avant sur votre fils et
que vous allez être en
en
en vision de ces contenus là le sujet
que vous évoquez c'est la question de
non seulement la construction
technologique de ses algorithmes la rue
chacun à sa façon de concevoir des
abords et chaque réseau social qu'on
soit sur la grille de façon il ya des
critères continue avec évidemment il ya
des critères des pondérations sur la
question de l'engagement de la
popularité de la page du contenu de la
viralité possible potentiel des scores
en fait il ya des scores c'est du
scoring
lorsque commencement pardonnez moi
c'était honte et chronologique c'est à
dire les postes arrivé en fonction de
données publiées et en fait
on a plutôt justement protection de
viralité d'économie de la tension est
donc en fait de modèle économique de
d'indicateurs de mesure pour la
publicité ciblée comportementale on a
plutôt privilégié des algorithmes une
recommandation qui était vraiment sur
dix ont la qualité entre guillemets des
contenus qu'ils allaient être mis en
avant et donc ce qu'on voit dans son fil
d'actualité jean-bernard est dicté par
ses algorithmes et qui nous pousse des
contenus qu'on n'a pas forcément
souhaitée mais qui sont recommandées
parce que c'est très difficile de faire
sans un algorithme pas ce que fait la
quantité le gigantisme de l'information
qui est circulait de toute façon
humainement on n'est pas apte de toute
façon à filtrer soit mais alors enfin
donc il ya un outillage qui est de toute
façon
nécessaire il n'est pas lourd et blâmer
cette allégorie alors parce qu'il n'est
pas question diriez vous avez
entièrement raison qu'on peut pas on ne
peut pas se passer car pas entièrement
se passe et d'algorithmes et puis tout
n'est pas mauvais dans les algorithmes
ça aussi c'est c'est vrai que ça devient
tout d'un coup on a du mal à expliquer
le mot depuis des années il a tout d'un
coup c'est devenu le diable incarné non
si j'aime le foot qu'on me des postures
et foot je serai ravi oui après problème
c'est un c est ce qu on vous suggère que
ça puis le foot c'est sympa quand c'est
pas le foot c'est beaucoup plus embêtant
je reviens toujours à mon problème de
polarisation et radicalisation parce que
si vous aimez quelque chose qui est
violent et c est qu on vous pousse que
ça parce que c'est ça qui se passe au
que j'avais ce problème deux ont parlé
de 2,2 de scoring la d'engagement
fièrement si vous n'êtes on ne vous
pousse que des postes que dès que des
publications parce que ça génère de
l'engagement et bien évidemment on va
aller dans le sens de antrim et tous vos
penchants c'est ça qui va pas et l'autre
chose d'approchant voilà exactement et
la deuxième chose c'est la transparence
c'est à dire que le minimum c'est de
savoir comment ça fonctionne et beaucoup
de choses que dix français socgen c'est
très intéressant c'est que beaucoup de
spécialistes disent c'est on ne sait pas
comment fonctionne la machine est un
moment ça peut faire partie des pistes
de régulation mais vous êtes aussi qu'on
le veuille ou non facebook les réseaux
sociaux général mais facebook fait
partie
intégrante de la conversation globale
c'est à dire que sa structure novice à
structure nos opinions sa structure
notre façon de voir le monde sa
structure notre vision du monde cette
responsabilité mais elle est
ensemble c'est pas comment ça fonctionne
vous laisser
entre les mains de deux personnes dont
vous ne savez pas encore une fois ce
qu'elle pense réellement ce qu'elles
veulent réellement énormément de votre
vision du monde se sent certainement
également une autre manière de consommer
parce que facebook le modèle de facebook
et des autres plateformes c'est aussi de
la publicité ciblée puisque rien n'est
gratuit sur facebook vous donnez vos
données et elles sont ciblées par la
publicité ou des contenus qui oriente
vos opinions et vos choix de distraction
et c'est donc c'est ça qui est qui est
assez grave et est assez dangereux et là
l'histoire de la transparence c'est le
vrai sujet d'ailleurs dans le texte
européen sur lequel nous travaillons en
ce moment il va y avoir des exigences de
transparence
la vraie question ça va être acquis
ouvres ton ses données et ses
algorithmes pour pouvoir être évalué
identifier les risques systémiques et
les évaluer et les corrigés avant même
qu'ils soient mis sur le marché dans
quelques cents quand vous sortez un
médicament vous sans dévaluer il fait
savoir avant qu'un nouveau réseau social
moi je dois créer voudriez que windham
suisse en public oui organes régulateurs
connaissent rappelle qu'on va légiférer
pas seulement pour facebook on va les
gérer sur l'ensemble des plateformes à
et tous les cfc juste une chose parce
qu'on en a parlé est ce que facebook
connaît lui-même les secrets tous ces
algorithmes pour est ce que ça lui a
échappé est ce qu on a cru lire ça va un
moment dans la révélation de selon
francis hogan pour écouter ce qu'elle a
dit cet après midi je lui explicitement
poser la question elle est très
importante et je vais même si est-ce que
c'est réparable ses algorithmes en
quelque sorte parce qu'il ya aussi des
caractères très positif est ce qu'elle
dit oui elle affirme que oui elle est
ingénieur spécialiste des algorithmes ça
veut dire que facebook c'est ce qu'il
fait ce facebook oriente volontairement
fonctions ce que dit françois seguin son
profit pour faire beaucoup d'argent ce
qui compte c'est faire beaucoup d'argent
le clic avec la publicité ciblée il est
rémunérateur et le problème de ces
plates formes que ce soit facebook
google amazon toutes ces plateformes
elle fonctionne comme ça ce modèle la
tension qui fait du clic rémunérateur
qui enrichit les plates formes qui sont
toujours plus puissantes qui ne payent
pas d'impôts et qui continue parce qu'il
ya aussi des problèmes de concurrence
déloyale tant que le dma sas le digitroc
est à voter eh bien elle absorbe au fur
et à mesure toutes les sociétés elles
les membres nous avons laissé des géants
devenir des most des mastodontes et
maintenant des monstres qui avale tout
sur leur passage d'où l'urgence question
urgence à légiférer mais voilà urgence à
légiférer parce que je trouve qu'on est
vraiment brillant dans le constat très
honnêtement moi je maintes et je
m'intéresse beaucoup à ces questions et
je trouve que le constat fait par les
spécialistes que vous êtes est excellent
mais l'urgence c'est de légiférer madame
nous sommes à cinq mois la
présidentielle j'ai juste une question
le scandale cambridge analytica c'était
l'exploitation de données sans le
consentement des internautes parce
qu'ils avaient répondu à un quiz qui
était rémunérateurs et facebook avaient
laissé filer les données ses
utilisateurs et cambridge hanatika en
fait après c'est un peu savant mais en
gros fait un peu sa cuisine et fait
ensuite du marketing politique ciblée
d'accord est ce que facebook ou non le
savez ça c'est aussi la responsabilité
facebook elle n'est pas déterminée un
d'accord est-ce que là c'est possible en
france est ce que un scandale à la
cambridge anna mika est possible là pour
la compagnie qui est déjà commencée
madame parce que l'urgence de légiférer
oui vous avez l'air de m'accuser je
voudrais quand même dire ici hausse
énorme police mais le politique au sénat
ils alertent depuis 2006 madame 2013
d'écrire un rapport qui s'appelle
l'union européenne colonie du monde
numérique où je mets en garde je parle
du politique à brno mais je veux
répondre où je mets en garde sur tout ce
qui est en train de se passer après au
lendemain du scandale snowdon nous
aurons ici 50 propositions citées en spa
en 2015 je dis qu'il faut ré ouvrir la
directive e-commerce qui régit le régime
de non responsabilité de nos
redevabilité des plateformes je n'ai
cessé de plaider presque dans le désert
depuis que nous légiférons sur la loi
visant à lutter contre la manipulation
de l'information des législations
nationales et parce je dis non c'est pas
ça le problème problème ce n'est pas les
contenus c'est la manière dont les
contenus qu'est ce qu'ils veulent on
vire au prix ce qui bloque parce que
nous dépendons du droit on remet bien
donc vous savez que c'est toujours long
ces directives elle a été votée en 2000
donc elle va être la réforme est assez
vite d'ailleurs nous demandons dans nos
rapports ici au sénat qu'on aille le
plus vite possible à appliquer le
digitals aux miss acte mais on
voit la présidence française ça va être
une impulsion en plus d'importance parce
que non c'est à nous aussi de veiller
dubitative je suis dubitatif sur un
certain nombre de sujets évidemment sur
les conseils je suis tellement d'accord
il ya quelques peut-être
la confusion mais on généralise un peu
trop toutes ces plates formes là qui
sont en fait assez différentes les unes
des autres et quand par rapport aux
déesses à le débat est un peu hors sujet
en langue ça le digital
le projet de loi qui était enfin
législatif qui a été présenté en fin
d'année dernière par la commission
européenne pour réguler ou réglementé
justement la modération des réseaux
sociaux là où je suis pas tellement
d'accord c'est que ce sont des bons
débuts c'est un bon démarrage breton
mais un très bon diagnostic et maîtrise
parfaitement ces enjeux là donc c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle en ce sens non
pêche que ça ne va pas sur les modèles
économiques je suis désolé c'est à dire
que quand on va auditer des algorithmes
peu importe ce qu'on va y trouver ils
seront toujours au service de la
viralité de l'économie de l'attention de
la publicité comportementale et donc peu
importe que l'algorithme échappe ou pas
techniquement puisque deux fait le filet
au sénat change quoi exactement donc il
ya ça ensuite sur la question des
plateformes le dsa a été conçu sur
mesure pour les gars femmes pour des
questions de souveraineté numérique
entre autres et c'est peut-être pas une
mauvaise chose en moi les gars famin
google amazon facebook apple mais tu as
maintenant rythme et à y venir je sais
désormais juillet juste ce qui
complètement mort hors périmètre de la
réflexion ce sont les petites
plateformes or ce sont celles ci qui
crée l'effet que muse le complotisme
c'est à râler parleurs et c est en fait
elle arrive derrière sur les big ticket
les méta plateforme par capillarité et
celles ci elles sont complètement sous
le radar du death alors vous avez raison
c'est la raison pour laquelle et par les
parlements des différents états membres
des 27 donne un avis sur le texte qui
est proposé donc nous nous avons pour
ambition de ré aussi justement
l'ambition du texte et les soleils oui
et surtout gateway les seuils les délais
tout ce que vous dites mais les mois que
j'ai tout ce que vous avez dit nous
l'avons pris en compte mais moi je dis
que ça ne suffit même pas les textes
européens c'est déjà une étape
importante mais ça ne vient même pas si
ce n'est pas assortie d'une politique
industrielle volontariste et puissant
parce que nous avons failli c'est à dire
construire depuis 30 ans nous n'avons
rien rien fait en matière d'art un peu
fait en matière de construction
progressive d'un écosystème souffre
et on se vend technologie extraire océan
tu vois là alors que nous avons les
meilleurs
on a les capacités en force on est ce qu
ils ont une captation des usagers de
l'expérience qui est inégalable pardon
sinon sinon on aurait déjà eu de la zulu
et je pense que nous sommes pas ou rien
le quatrième
en
matière d'intelligence artificielle de
création de logiciels nous avons les
meilleures écoles d'arrivée
parce qu'il n'ya pas de jolies attendiez
menthe à l'eau chaude qui sont les
révélations ces domaines il faut que
tout le monde quand même nous nous
entendons nous comprennent dans les
révélations de français sodium il ya
cette question des algorithmes et il ya
aussi des révélations dans quête interne
menée par facebook sur des applications
que le groupe possède un méta parlons
maintenant c'est ce que c'est le nouveau
nom on y reviendra notamment instagram
qui serait une enquête interne qui
jugeraient que ces toxiques notamment
pour les jeunes filles sur une image
très dégradée de leur corps d'autres sur
évidemment dans cette économie de
l'addiction qui pousse les gens parfois
à la dépression parce qu'on se trouve à
un utilisateur sur cette streif
considérée comme addict donc ça veut
dire drogués par ces réseaux sociaux est
ce que facebook est dangereux mais alors
est-ce que c'est une nocifs enfin c'est
difficile de dire aussi moi j'ai mon
avis personnel qui est extrêmement
réticent mcdonald's ou pas mais ce dont
je sais noces il faut le laisser dans la
merde adolescente non alors déjà je
pense qu'effectivement là pour le coup
c'est pas une position scientifique
parce que j'ai pas toutes les données ça
met de fait on devrait énormément se
méfier de ce qu'on fait de ce qu'on
laisse faire aux jeunes sur les réseaux
sociaux pour plein de raisons et d'abord
parce qu'il s'agit d'une économie de
l'attention et que ça capte trop leur
attention par rapport à d'autres choses
mais je reviens sur ce que vous disiez
dangereux à voir et là c'est un vrai
débat aussi je dirais philosophique et
anthropologique mais
ce que vous notez la sur instagram ça
montre bien ce que je disais au début
c'est quand même qu'ils sont conscients
de beaucoup de choses voir qu'ils en
sont complices parce que sur instagram
vous avez donc ce rapport sur la
nocivité vis-à-vis des adolescentes vous
en avez un autre très intéressant sur le
fait qu' ils ont un double système de
modération à l'intérieur de d'instagram
en haut un système pour le grand public
et un système pour les happy few pour
les vip qui peut contourner et c'est un
les règles et on va dire que don en gros
il ya un exemple qui est s'il n'a pas
qu'un seul exemple de citer une photo
publiée par un footballeur célèbre d'une
de ses anciennes conquêtes qui
l'accusait de de d'agression sexuelle
il l'a publié sur les réseaux sociaux en
l'occurrence sur instagram c'est avec
brosses et assimilés à du ruisseau torna
donc ça théoriquement ces bannissements
ou en tout cas suspensions etc en fait
sa photo elle a été retiré au bout de
trois jours 56 millions de vues et donc
la lune et physique
je vous propose juste d'écouter un
extrait de la réponse de laurent solly
le patron de facebook france quand on
interroge justement sur ces critiques
sur sur ce terme la conclusion de cette
étude que vous citez est fausse c'est
une étude qui a été faite sur des jeunes
femmes qui éprouvaient une forme de mal
être quarante personnes ont été
interrogées sur douze critères l'anxiété
la tristesse la solitude onze des points
montre qu instagram selon elle améliore
leur vie sociale un impact positif
c'est une question visiteurs faisons fi
xé quasi sociologique ces mêmes
problématiques éducatives et vous
faisiez allusion à cette question de la
modération ça aussi ça a été soulignée
par français sauvegarde avoir la
modération vous allez nous expliquer ce
que c'est catherine morin desailly et
pourquoi on n'est pas modéré de la même
façon les contenus sont d'un pays à
l'autre c'est comment dirais je
une façon qu'à facebook de tenter de
réguler les contenus en réalité qui
d'hôtel c'est pratiquement auto dotée
mais certains politiques ou non certains
gouvernements dans certains pays y
compris en france on peut miser sur
cette capacité à s'auto réguler à se
modérer notre gouvernement actuel de n'y
a pas échappé il ya quelques années au
lendemain de la faire comme magnétique à
nous ici nous avons toujours dit que la
modération ne suffisait absolument
compte tenu de ce que vous avez expliqué
monsieur j'adore un article du
washington post et disent même que euros
facebook n'a supprimé que 5% des 18e
alors que bien sûr d'abord on voit que
ça varie selon les pays et selon les
langues la capacité aussi avoir un
nombre de modérateur suffisant etc non
moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment être au
coeur de la machine de la black box
pouvoir y rentrer et déterminer là où il
ya un vrai après pour revenir juste sur
un statut vous dire à ceux qui nous
écoutent que instagram c'est facebook
c'est comme whatsapp c'est la même chose
si on est dans la même entreprise oncle
même le même modèle alors est-ce qu'il
faut réguler démanteler nationaliser
supprimés je voudrais passer la parole à
georg ricqlès pourquoi les géants du
numérique gheorghe classons ont échappé
jusqu'à présent à toute tentative de de
régulation
je pense que ce constat est très
important et cette question est très
importante si les plateformes ont pris
le pouvoir et ont pu faire ce qu'elles
font aujourd'hui c'est qu'on leur a
laissé ce pouvoir c'est tout à fait
juste ce que ce qui a été dit le cadre
était celui de l'autorégulation ça vient
de la loi américaine de la section la
femme de section de 130 de la loi de
télécommunications de 1996 qui disait
que ces plateformes au ses acteurs ne
sont pas responsables des contenus qui
transitent dans leur système et puis
cela comme été dit par la sénatrice a
été repris dans la loi européenne en
2000 et sa clause safe harbor donc tout
cela ça vient d'une idéologie au fond on
se disait que internet est neutre
l'internet c'est la démocratie mais bien
sûr il y avait aussi des intérêts
économiques énormes derrière donc on est
dans un cas assez classique de ce qu'on
appelle de capture réglementaire est
donc aujourd'hui ce qui ce qui est très
attristant c'est de ce sentiment en
effet que notre avenir n'est plus dans
les mains de nos démocraties mais il se
fait
à silicon valley des ingénieurs qui
jouent aux apprentis sorciers des
patrons qui se font des profits
monstrueux et puis n'oublions pas aussi
ce qui se passe en chine en ce moment
dans d'autres modèles donc une des
pistes pardon je vous interromps c'est
de responsabiliser ces plateformes de
leur donner comme un statut d'éditeur de
contenus non pas seulement d'hébergeur
tout à fait c'est absolument vital que
on sort de cette année moi anomalies et
d'ailleurs même dans la loi américaine
cette section de 130 est une anomalie si
on regarde la réglementation américaine
sur des produits l'on parle là de des
contenus de presse la poste le
télégramme la radio la télé certes après
des batailles mais toujours il ya eu un
double principe dans la loi américaine
qui était celle d'une part de protéger
la communication individuelle mais
d'autre part de
imposer une responsabilité pour le bien
public et des diffuseurs de contenus et
donc c'est réellement un cadre
d'autorégulation et d'exemptions de
responsabilité qu'on a eu et dont il
faut faire subir maintenant une
révolution copernicienne les photos ont
des ce modèle est donc ça c'est dans les
tuyaux oui moi en tout cas c'est mon
intention de contribuer à faire quelque
chose avance dans ce sens là je pense
que si on prend peau on reprend les
propos du président de l'union charles
michel il disait fin septembre il y a la
place pour une troisième voie européenne
un modèle centré sur l'homme sur nos
droits fondamentaux qui n'est ni le
modèle américain qui est business volent
les affaires le profit avant tout qui
n'est pas non plus modèle chinois qui
est le modèle du crédit social et de la
surveillance des individus chantôme est
un modèle dans lequel on redonne à
l'internet sa qualité sa valeur
d'origine où il y a des libertés
fondamentales la liberté d'entreprendre
la liberté aussi de pouvoir conserver
une vie privée est peut-être un modèle
de civilisation qui est autre chose que
ce que nous proposent les réseaux les
réseaux sociaux et qui était extrêmement
destructeur je trouve de facebook une
plate forme familiale des changes
sympathique entre amis on retrouvait les
amis etc on est venu à un modèle de
média social qui remontent les uns
contre les autres qui créent des
communautés conflictuelle qui fait
monter les radicalismes les
fondamentalistes bref c'est un outil
mais désastreux séjour du coran on
pourrait garder le bon côté de facebook
communication la solidarité sociale en
france des ingénieurs des chercheurs des
entrepreneurs qui souhaitent qu'on aille
vers des modèles ce qu'ils appellent les
green tech donc les tec verte le slow
web le donc le web plutôt à l'anti en
tout cas qu'on travaille à des
l'émergence de nouveaux écosystèmes des
technologies vous savez ça avance très
pense qu'il ya plein de choses qu'on
avant et on avance vers des nouveaux
modèles beaucoup plus vertueux pas ce
modèle de la tension toxiques et pervers
tels que
régis nos plateformes à leurs acteurs
dont je vous rappelle quand même
qu'avant d'arriver au niveau de facebook
ça va être compliqué parce que c'est
quand même 2 8 milliards d'utilisateurs
à travers le monde je fais c'est pour ça
que de fait il faut en france certains
cancers est dur ce sont des hommes à
cheval et à quelle échelle ça se joue ça
peut se jouer à l'échelle européenne
nous faut que ça se joue à l'échelle
mondiale où j'allais dire économique
tout enfin tous les échelons d'action en
france on a eu un paquet de lois voilà
qui était plutôt sûr de la censure et du
sur contrôle loi via par exemple qui a
été retoquée par le conseil dans la loi
séparatisme récemment non non non une
partie la salle idée par le conseil
constitutionnel la partie rapidement
l'ascendant en tant que transposition en
avance du dessin
à l'échelle donc européenne évidemment
avec le dessin mais qui j'aurais placé
lecture comprennent c'est à dire que si
on demande de modérer les contenus sur
facebook qui peut partir d'un bon
principe est bien le mauvais principe
enfin le mauvais le revers de la
médaille c'est que ça donne ne peut
donner lieu à de la censure et à une
forme de film de contraintes de la
liberté d'expression wife and noir et
blanc quand construire solutions simples
en court-circuitant notamment le rôle du
juge et ce qui est donc un danger
démocratique majeur et puis surtout ce
sont des plateformes alors peu importe
enfin il ya tout un débat sur convient
d'avoir sur le statut hébergeur éditeur
très bien mais tant qu'on n'a pas statué
sur le statut de ce qu'est une donnée
personnelle sur le modèle économique le
ciblage publicitaire pour a changé que
ça veut dire qu'ils vont interdire
c'était sur facebook panoplie et il va y
avoir une incompatibilité entre le
statut hébergeurs éditeurs c'est à dire
que on pourra mettre toutes les chaînes
de responsabilité juridique et légal du
monde si le modèle économique est donc
la gouvernance privé c'est une des
récents avec ce que j'ai dit alors que
plus de problèmes
jusqu'à moi je pense justement là pour
bien comprendre ce à dire qu'il faut
interdire la publicité sur facebook
c'est à dire de l'enfer changer le smic
ou alors est ce qu'il faut sur dix est
d'organismes mondiale une
publicité sur nos gouvernants de ces
applications mondiales il ya il ya deux
choses
il ya deux choses il ya la question
évidemment du modèle économique et donc
de la réglementation en tout cas de la
publicité en ligne comportementale qui
en plus n'est pas que comportemental qui
est prédictive donc manipulatoire et qui
donc pas très grave je pense que en
europe droits de l'homme etc donc il ya
tout un discours sur les valeurs ça a
été trompée troisième voie européenne on
pourrait interdire le marketing
politique le ciblage politiques
notamment en période électorale de façon
radicale et définitive par exemple si on
ne le fait pas pour éviter dé cambridge
analytique à ce qui se passe en birmanie
au vietnam etc et puis évidemment ça
reste des plateformes américaines de
droits américains dans une guerre
géopolitique face à la chine et de ce
point de vue là l'europe va falloir
qu'elle bronze l'armée sur la saq se
sont amassés que nous sommes voilà d'un
côté ou de l'autre je pense que l'europe
et sa place au milieu et qu'elle a à
promouvoir quelque chose parce que on
est regardé de vraiment de manière très
attentive sur par exemple le règlement
général la protection des données on est
admirée de par le monde sur ce règlement
sur la protection des néons d'avoir été
capable de faire émerger
sur les droits d'auteur et droits
voisins qui va aussi aider la presse à
pouvoir aussi
c'est le mot qui a été capable de faire
ça dommage sera capable je termine nous
sommes capables de faire émerger en tout
cas de créer une dynamique fasse émerger
un troisième modèle parce que
aujourd'hui l'internet stories de
balkanisation c'est-à-dire
d'éparpillement de de dissociation parce
que les internautes les gens dans le
monde sont à quai et ils sont bons il se
pose des questions je voudrais juste
passer la parole à agay or gris cnes
pour pour lui demander de réagir à ce
qu'il entend à ce que pensait que
l'europe est la bonne échelle et surtout
est-ce que vous pensez que les européens
vont parler d'une voix commune sur ces
sujets là on sait que par exemple
irlande qui abritait des sièges sociaux
de deux de ses réseaux sociaux n'a
peut-être pas forcément la même vision
des choses que la france
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une vraie
difficulté de parler avec une voix
commune se mettent d'accord sur un
certain nombre de ces sujets je pense
que le débat qu'on voit actuellement il
va certainement aider
je pense que par rapport à ce qui est
dit on voit plein de défis il y en a
d'autres qui arrivent aussi à le défi de
l'intelligence artificielle qu'il faut
aussi encadrer on voyait j'écoutais
l'autre jour le l'ex patron de google
eric schmidt qui lancé une petite alerte
il disait
attention l'intelligence artificielle le
cocktail qui est en train d'être produit
ne va pas servir l'humain il va falloir
que qu'on se pose la question de ce qui
est une intelligence artificielle
meilleur ami de notre enfant de nos
enfants ou quelles seront les guère régi
par l'intelligence artificielle à
l'avenir alors que ce même eric schmidt
en tant que patron de google est à 5 ans
en 2016 signer des tribunes où il disait
ne paniquez pas il faut pas avoir peur
de l'intelligence artificielle donc
c'est clair qu'il ya quelque chose qui
était en train de se passer l'europe
doit utiliser au mieux son pouvoir de
réglementation
mais je pense pas que ce sera suffisant
et ce qui me vient à l'esprit c'est la
crise financière de 2008 on avait
découvert qu' il y avait des acteurs
financiers la crise des sub des
subprimes souvenez vous souvenez vous
qui transformé et des dettes pourries
les titrisés et les vendée pour le plus
grand profit dans la plus grande opacité
opacité et ça fait tomber le système
financier mondial ça fait tomber
l'économie mondiale mais au fond ce que
fait facebook aujourd'hui avec les
contenus en ligne c'est un peu la même
chose ils les mettent ensemble leurs
algorithmes
donne un biais positif à ce qui provoque
à ceux qui génèrent déclic pour générer
des profits mais la réponse après la
crise financière à cette crise des
subprimes à aux agissements de deux de
ses acteurs fils en financiers ça a été
un cadre global où on a dit plus aucun
produit plus aucun marché plus d'aucun
acteur sans régulation efficace et
supervision appropriés donc je pense
qu'il ya un vrai enjeu aussi pour
l'europe de réussir à porter ce débat
au niveau mondial dans un premier lieu
avec l'administration byden avec une
administration américaine ya des gens au
congrès aussi qu'ils sont très
préoccupés par ce qui s'y passe j'ai
avec nous jean bernard schmid qui n'a
aucun rapport il faut que la
chance aurait pu être intéressant mais
non c'est non non pas du tout non mais
juste pour compléter des choses parce
que la réalité c'est que on va avoir du
mal à faire changer tout ça mais c'est
normal aussi on est face à c'est ce que
vous disiez au début ce sont des
mastodontes qui attire énormément de
choses de de gens qui ont sonné d'un
usage énormément énormément d'argent
neuf milliards d'euros de bénéfices pour
le sol
et voilà donc les attentions et qui sont
rentrés ce qu'ils se sont assignés dans
nos vies au plus profond plus intimes de
nos vies oui au début vous avez demandé
est ce qu'on apprend quelque chose et on
a tous fait la même erreur
stereau dit non en fait on n'apprend pas
grand chose mais si en fait il faut se
mettre à la place du grand public le
grand public en fait ne sait pas ce
qu'il fait on parle de publicité ciblée
il n'est pas question d'interdire la
publicité je pense ça sera très
difficile sur facebook ou alors ça sera
castrés tout le modèle mais déjà la
publicité ciblée ça pose énormément de
problèmes donc déjà si on dit aux gens à
temps son attention c'est pas pour rien
que vous voyez cette publicité sépare
vous avez laïque et ça c'est parce que
vous avez partagé ça c'est parce que
attention c'est pire vous êtes allé sur
un autre site qui n'a rien à voir avec
facebook mais on vous a repéré la cible
est derrière toi ne croyons pas que nous
effectivement spécialistes nous savons
tout ça le grand public le ces je vous
en donne un autre exemple vous avez la
possibilité sur facebook de récupérer
vos données personnelles mais fait
l'expérience on peut le dire à tous ceux
qui nourrira fait l'expérience vous
allez tomber de votre chaise c'est à
dire qu'une fois vous allez récupérer
les fichiers que facebook a sur vous
toutes vos géolocalisation toutes vos
connexions depuis votre inscription sur
le réseau avec l'endroit où vous êtes
connecté en général tout votre carnet
d'adressés y compris les gens qui ne
sont pas sur facebook et in fine et les
sur les cinq six dernières semaines
toutes les marques qui ont utilisé vos
données facebook pour vous ciblez mais
je peux vous garantir que des charges
east vous apprenez énormément de choses
et rance et que ce constat donc il ya
encore une fois partagé il est connu au
plus haut sommet de l'état emmanuel
macron s'est fait lui même piraté
pendant la campagne précédente elle est
ma chronique soit rappelée par les
russes at il dit est que la à l'elysée
ils ont mis en place une cellule mais
qui est ridicule c'est ridicule au
niveau de l'exécutif il ya dix personnes
peut-être et encore je suis secrétaire
faudrait un kit et nicolas ont fait ça
c'est à dire un scénario comme les états
unis comme obama avait incité au c'est à
dire quelqu'un qui a autorité sur
l'ensemble des ministères et qui
développe et qu'ils fassent
soit la globale et cohérente elle n'est
pas cohérent aujourd'hui facebook mais
mme et à ce nouveau monde virtuel dans
lequel veut nous invité mark zuckerberg
ce qui est assez inquiétant fluoration
très inconstant il pour beaucoup
d'autres problèmes tout est fait que ce
soit comportementaux on va veut des pour
un président virtuel oui c'est sûr
d'avoir envie de vivre dans un monde
virtuel gérée par facebook surtout pas
mais on peut la présidentielle ce sont
des
noms mais ce sont des extraits
entreprise extrêmement récente qui ont
entre parenthèses révolutionner une
partie de notre vie et du monde c'est
normal aussi que l'arrivée c'est aussi
ces plaisirs mais oui et puis c'est
aussi normal que la régulation prennent
du temps si on prend juste un exemple ya
cent ans globalement les états unis ont
réussi à ont réussi à démanteler des
énormes compagnies pétrolières qui
avaient pris trop de place dans pays
dont un qui sait pas non plus un oui
c'est de réguler or facebook et gratuit
ce qui est
différent
merci d'avoir participé à ce débat merci
à tous les cinq à ce moment-là laetitia
culpa catherine morin desailly georg
ricqlès depuis bruxelles et puis jean
bernard schmidt merci à tous ce rendez
vous dès lundi à 18 heures avec thomas
hugues pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public bonne soirée